i'm going to win and i'm going to be
smiling the whole time because i beat
your son
that is funny that's a joke you beat my
son i will come up shake your head and
congratulate you that's not going to
happen chuck
hey google start a group call
hey guys what's up yo man are you
cooking a turkey it better not be dry
this turkey's gonna be nice never messed
one up yet what's going on chef hey i
don't think any last minute practice is
going to help you right now thanks what
can i do to get on the stiff skin right
before he's about to putt just ask him
is my mark okay if it's a little closer
i might get in his head and put a little
extra pressure on him i'm not sure
that'll be an option for you chuck you
know your ball has to be closer to the
hole in order to market first deal be
nice i don't want to bring up my stats
against you this is not the 90s and i'm
going to go out on a limb and say i'm in
a little better shape than you so we can
take it to the court next time i see you
hey this is a different game now chuck
we shooting three ball they use all the
paint you got to bring it out and extend
that range these days my guy i'm not
even going to dignify that with a
response
i'm going to win and you're going to
come and walk up to me and shake my hand
and say congratulations
that is funny i've seen both of you play
you have no shot let's make a bet if i
hit it on the green on the 19th hole you
take me to your club for the buffet the
19th hole isn't that an island green you
hit the green i'll take you to my club
i'm buying the buffet dinner bet the
buffet
i just saw your eyes light up when you
said that hey man have a good time
goodbye and save me some of that dry
turkey bye chuck
[Music]
if i get them like that i'll be rbi